[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24 y
conmigo está el estudio más romeros a la
mar bienvenida un feliz mañana del
jueves vamos a hablar entonces de una
cifra impactante no la brecha salarial
entre hombres y mujeres por supuesto en
el campo de salud qué lástima que esto
sea desigual si estamos haciendo lo
mismo
así es raúl le sigue al final el mundo
de la salud no es exento de muchísimas
desigualdades discriminaciones de género
y en este caso discriminaciones
económicas estamos hablando de un
informe publicado por la oms y la
organización internacional del trabajo
que muestra como decíamos esta brecha
salarial profunda entre hombres y
mujeres que desarrollan los mismos
trabajos estamos hablando de un 24 por
ciento de diferencias salariales en el
trabajo en el ámbito sanitario y todo
eso además reconociendo que las mujeres
son el 67 por ciento de las personas que
trabajan en este ámbito eso quiere decir
que casi que casi 7 de cada 10 personas
esos trabajadores de la salud
trabajadores de sanitarios son mujeres
sin embargo siguen cobrando mucho menos
ocupan puestos diferentes según reporta
este informe los puestos de poder siguen
estando más ocupados por hombres que por
mujeres algo que contribuye de hecho a
esta misma brecha salarial porque
también son los puestos donde pues se
cobra más e incluso son en estos puestos
de poder de más responsabilidad donde la
diferencia entre hombres y mujeres que
ejercen la misma profesión es más amplia
y este no es marc sin embargo el único
problema porque hay millones de mujeres
que realizan trabajos de salud sin ni
siquiera cobrar nada si de hecho
recuperando este informe debe de la ms
vamos a rescatar otro que se publicó la
semana pasada the global women health
estamos hablando de 6 millones de
mujeres en todo el mundo que realizan
trabajos básicos de atención sanitaria
sin cobrar nada básicamente pues al
final sosteniendo sistemas de salud que
sin este trabajo no remunerado y por lo
tanto muchas veces no reconocido tampoco
se derrumbarían totalmente un ejemplo
por ejemplo de hecho es el de más
amplios en esos trabajos que se
desarrollan en casa que forman parte de
lo que se entiende como cuidado
doméstico de familiares de otras
personas que si no tuvieran ese cuidado
de muchas de estas mujeres deberían
acudir
hospital tener ayuda profesional y
probablemente acudir a unos sistemas
sanitarios que no pueden acoger los de
hecho sin embargo también hay casos de
mujeres que trabajan desarrollando ya
tareas más profesionalizadas en centros
de salud que lo hacen sin pago sin
ningún tipo de remuneración y esto
porque sucede pues porque muchas veces
se considera este trabajo sanitario como
un servicio a la salud como un servicio
a la comunidad que parece ser natural lo
que se entiende es una serie de
prejuicios que es natural en las mujeres
como extensión de esa labor de cuidados
y de crianza que tradicionalmente se
asocia a pues al rol en las familias de
las mujeres además en la pandemia
también muchísimas de estas mujeres
tuvieron roles primordiales en por
ejemplo las estrategias de vacunación en
difundir
informaciones sobre las vacunas sobre
los contactos sobre los contagios que
tampoco han sido pues reconocidos al
menos a través de una remuneración la
conclusión de estos dos informes al
final es que las mujeres pues están
aportando mayor atención social están
aportando funciones más allá del
conocimiento científico están aportando
este o doméstico a cambio recibiendo
mayor inseguridad laboral de ahorro
salario y menos puestos de liderazgo
bueno mar lamentable situación esperemos
que esta brecha se cierre lo antes
posible por ahí le informa la
organización que lo hice como que tienen
que pasar tienen que pasar como 124 años
para que esta brecha sin embargo en
manos de esta de todos acelerarlo por
favor vamos a pasar a otro tema mar y
nosotros pues obviamente no dejamos
atrás las noticias que hemos venido es
recurrentemente hablando de nuestro
espacio nuevos datos sobre la partita
infantil aguda de origen desconocido si
es una cosa que generó mucha alarma hace
unos meses y que habíamos dejado un poco
de lado como mínimo pues al menos
recuperar los últimos datos que ayer
publicó la organización mundial de la
salud estamos hablando 1010 casos en
todo el mundo de estos el 5 por ciento
han necesitado un trasplante de hígado
mientras que 22 casos siendo eso el 2
por ciento de todos estos casos
reportados mundialmente han fallecido 22
víctimas mortales e infantiles además se
ha detectado en 35 países de estos 35
países la mayoría son europeos
especialmente reino unido y luego el 33
de los casos también al otro lado del
mar en estados unidos- pasando
rápidamente aquí en américa latina se
han detectado casos en brasil argentina
y colombia a todos menos de 5 casos por
ahora en cambio méxico ya lleva varias
decenas aunque sean menos menos de 100
todavía mar y le pregunto si digamos ha
habido avances en esta investigación del
origen de estos casos de hepatitis la
verdad es que no en esto no podemos
reportar novedades y la verdad es que
falta consenso prácticamente en todo
incluido y empezando hay una falta de
consenso incluso de si hay un repunte de
estos casos de hepatitis infantil de
hecho los cdc los centros de control y
prevención de enfermedades de eeuu
publicaron datos mostrando desde el 2019
cuánto habían avanzado estos casos y
habían subido o no y vemos que en
realidad la línea que muestran dos
distintas edades pero todos menores de
11 años no cambia especialmente 2019
2020 2021 los años de pandemia las
limitaciones que 2022 que es el año en
que más casos el reportado pues no hay
tantas cifras todavía sin embargo a
pesar de estos datos hay muchísimos
expertos que siguen muy convencidos de
que la pandemia tuvo algo que ver que
alguna cosa tiene que ver con las
vacunas por cierto muy bajo porcentaje
de estos niños con estos casos habían
sido vacunados por lo tanto la sociedad
no va por ahí pero de alguna otra forma
ese timing tan preciso tiene que estar
conectado por la pandemia hay otros
defensores que dicen que esto es culpa
del adenovirus 41 que ya ha sido uno de
los sospechosos más nombrados es un tipo
de virus de resfriado común que pues hay
algunos nuevos estudios que apoyan esta
teoría aunque con muestras muy pequeñas
diciendo que las y los niños que
desarrollaron una enfermedad más severa
tenían una carga viral más alta de este
adenovirus
41 sin embargo por ejemplo no habían
encontrado estos virus tampoco en los
tejidos del hígado por lo tanto no hay
nada concluyente todavía como decimos ni
siquiera con el número de cifras
entonces pues toca estar muy pendientes
y también dejar que los expertos hagan
su trabajo por supuesto mar muchísimas
gracias como siempre por hablar de salud
en esta mañana derecho américa mañana
con más vamos a pasar a saludar a
nuestro segundo invitado al día